in der nacht fällt der regen auf das
dorfcafé rock und das dortige
flüchtlingslager ein selbst gebautes
zellen mehr schutz haben abo klev und
seine frau nicht für ihre kinder walid
ist fünf jahre alt oma vier jahre gas
als zehn insgesamt sind sie sechs
geschwister als ersatz armee immer
weiter gegen sein heimatdorf vorrückte
ist der bauer mit seiner familie
geflüchtet
in den von rebellen aber auch von
dschihadisten kontrollierten teil
eclipse in dieser nacht fürchtet abpfiff
keine bombenangriffe sondern das was ihm
in seinem vorherigen leben als bauer
willkommen war den regen das wasser es
sicher durch den bereits vollgesogenen
boden unaufhaltsam es steht schon im
vorzelt
ich darf nicht einschlafen solange die
kinder schlafen ich fürchte das wasser
und dass die kinder krank werden oder
sterben
ich bleibe wach und gucke was passiert
das gesamte umland von kafka rock ist
überschwemmt weit mehr als eine halbe
million flüchtlinge so schätzt die uhren
hc sind allein seit märz 2009 10 in die
provinz idlib geflüchtet die offiziellen
flüchtlingslager sind überfüllt
zehntausende syrische binnenflüchtlinge
stranden deshalb in selbstgebauten
lagern wie hier errichtet auf
unbefestigte erde nicht mal
schottersteine als untergrund die
sanitären anlagen es sind nein es waren
einfache ärger hinter den zelten jetzt
ausgespült vom dauerregen alles vermengt
in fützen
vier kinder sind in den letzten wochen
in den lagern in der region idleb
gestorben an unterkühlung und
infektionen
das nächste kleine krankenhaus ist elf
kilometer entfernt und kostet geld das
abo kleff nicht hat die kinder dürfen
einfach nicht ernsthaft krank werden
bakterien teiche die apoplex kinder
durch warten müssen
der boden ist man hier können wir nicht
leben
wir kämpfen um jeden meter damit wir
wenigstens sitzen können wir schütten
das wasser hier raus und es kommt dort
wieder rein
ich habe kein schutz darf und ich muss
hierbleiben es trägt sie die hoffnung
dass ihre arme länger wasser schöpfen
können als der regen andauert und dass
das wasser durch die selbst geschaufelt
rennen abfließen möge daniel gerlach
orientalist und nahost-experte verfolgt
den syrien-konflikt von beginn an diese
gegend blieb das war mal die kornkammer
funktionen und das war die
landwirtschaftliche hochburg des landes
von dort kam gemüse obst und insofern
ist wenigstens in der gegend noch
landwirtschaft zu betreiben ist noch
fruchtbares land aber insgesamt ist die
situation für diese leute natürlich
völlig aussetzen
als abbruchreif vor fast einem jahr mit
seiner familie hier ankam waren sie
einfach nur froh ihre zelte aufschlagen
zu dürfen
unter trockenen olivenbäumen das land
stellte ein bauer aus dem dorf zur
verfügung
umgerechnet 1 eur 78 hat er für den
einkauf es reicht gerade für brot
tomaten und ein paar gurken
vor seiner flucht bestellte abpfiff
seine eigenen felder hatte schafe und
hühner jetzt ist er ein geduldeter auf
fremdem land seine kinder können nicht
in die schule gehen und ab hat keine
arbeit kein verdienst
er muss jeden tag aufs neue versuchen
genug essen für seine familie zu
besorgen lahmacun auf arabisch teig mit
fleisch es muss ohne gehen fleisch ist
ein nahezu unbezahlbarer luxus nicht
wenige landbesitzer vertreiben
flüchtlinge sie fürchten dass sie
bleiben dass immer mehr kommen
und genau das geschieht auch im café
woche um woche wächst die zeltstadt vor
dem dorf sind die ärmsten der armen
ich finde es faszinierend dass trotzdem
nach so vielen jahren die menschen
sondern überlebenswillen haben in syrien
gibt es über 1000 flüchtlingslager nur
eine randnotiz im bürgerkrieg gerade
dschihadistische gruppen nutzen die
notlage sie leisten humanitäre hilfe um
menschen für ihre sache zu gewinnen gar
kämpfer zu rekrutieren
in café bus sind es die örtlichen bauern
die sauberes trinkwasser liefern die
helfen wo sie können und vor diesem
hintergrund ist es auch wahrscheinlich
dass wenn kinder in ein bestimmtes
sogenanntes wehrhaftes alter kommen dass
sie sich dann bewaffneten gruppen
anschließen werden weil sie keine chance
haben einen beruf zu lernen oder in
irgendeiner form sich eine
zukunftsperspektive aufzubauen so dass
wir da einen clip sehen ist eine sehr
langsam tickende zeitbombe aber es ist
auf jeden fall eine zeitbombe weniger
als drei flugstunden von europa entfernt
nach dem regen kommt der frost dieser
winter ist erbarmungslos das
assad-regime verhindert hilfslieferungen
in die rebellengebiete je schlechter es
den menschen hier geht desto besser
steht das regime selbst vor der eigenen
bevölkerung dar so das kalkül in
damaskus abpfiff konnte seinen ofen aus
dem hochwasser retten
doch es fehlt an brennholz und das
wenige ist nass viele flüchtlinge
verbrennen in ihrer not plastik trotz
der giftigen dämpfe
mehr auch als feuer auch deshalb wird
der ofen nur stundenweise befeuert
[Musik]
hinter oma ballett und ihren
geschwistern liegen lange winter wochen
und vor ihnen nur eine perspektive
sie lautet durchhalten überleben